Tom Hanks and Rita Wilson are giving
fans an update on their health after
testing positive for coronavirus the
married couple posted this photo with
the caption hello folks Rita Wilson and
I want to thank everyone here down under
who are taking such good care of us we
have Co vid 19 and are in isolation so
we do not spread it to anyone else there
are those for whom it could lead to a
very serious illness we are taking it
one day at a time there are things we
can all do to get through this by
following the advice of experts and
taking care of ourselves in each other
no remember despite all the current
events there is no crying in baseball
Hanks that's of course a reference to
Tom's classic a league of their own on
Wednesday Tom confirmed both he and Rita
tested positive for coronavirus while
shooting the untitled Elvis Presley
biopic in Australia if their son Chet
took to Instagram to provide an update
on his parents that same day what's up
everyone oh yeah it's true my parents
got coronavirus crazy but I just got off
the phone with them they both are fine
they're not even that sick they're not
worried about it
they're not trippin but they're going
through the necessary health precautions
obviously and Hollywood has been
reacting to Tom and Rita's surprising
diagnosis we just heard Tom Hanks and
Rita Wilson were diagnosed with a corona
virus so what was your initial reaction
along with the rest of the world that
found out I'm sending speedy recovery
prayers for both of them Tom Hanks he's
like the president of Hollywood you know
yes I think it's important that Tom and
Rita spoke out because they are allowing
people to see that this disease this
virus is non-discriminating
and that we must protect ourselves at
all cost there's a lot of council if
people you really trust people who are
getting really good information clearer
information but it's I completely I feel
just as stressed and worried as
everybody else out there I think we
share that we both have little children
and we both have elderly parents yes so
that's what we get what do you call that
the Sandwich Generation
and I think that's a lot on people's
minds scaring you took her anything yeah
I just think it's a time when it we all
have to strike a tricky balance between
making sure that we stay informed and
are getting the facts so that we can
make decisions to help take care of
ourselves and the people around us that
we love and also try not to panic right
and try to especially at this time
elevated levels of stress impact our
immune systems so that level of
self-care and calm is important not just
theoretically but really physically
you